man take the back your knife is really  important now I have a sharper the knife  okay and we're gonna score very gently  basically this is for sort of decoration  right turn the tray around we're gonna  do again the other side really important  back of the knife otherwise you cut  through the pastry and spoil gun crews  now great action by the way pallet knife  mark half way down through the salmon  and then half and half again basically  okay we're portioning it up so it comes  out that we know where to slice now  touch of salt put your pepper what I'm  doing yeah and then okay that is now  ready for the other one yes good Patsy  that looks fantastic bit of salt and  pepper on top now and if Percy kids you  can do it anybody can do it now  hold on yes together just be fine right  Hollis fix it here we go now turn into  the oven let's go [ __ ] shelf